MARTIN AGUINIS: Hey, I'm
Martin, and I'm standing here
with Tao and Ja Young
from our UX Research team
here at Google.
So I wanted to
start by asking you,
what do you exactly do
as part of UX at Google,
specifically in Flutter?
TAO DONG: I see UX
in general as trying
to make sure our product
development is centered
on user needs and to make sure
they are usable and useful.
But our work on
Flutter is a little bit
different from
general UX, because we
will have a developer product.
And we try to make sure the team
understands that programming
and app development is an
inherently human process
and human activity.
We want to make sure the
features, the documentation,
the API we design and
implement, satisfy user needs
and allow the developer to
move as fast as they could
without frictions and seams
when they use our tools.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Could
you maybe share with us
a recent study or
something you've
done to try and understand
our users as part of a Flutter
effort?
JA YOUNG SUNG: I've been running
Flutter User Survey, so thanks
all for participating in.
We've learned a
lot from our users,
and our main goal is to bridge
the gap between the users
and our engineers,
so that we can
help our engineers to
prioritize their time and effort
in developing Flutter.
MARTIN AGUINIS: So in doing
these types of things,
was there something that was
surprising or shocking as you
did these research projects?
TAO DONG: Yeah, so we had
a recent online experiment
where we look at different ways
to improve our error messages.
And many of the
community members
actually participated
in this experiment--
thank you for your
participation-- but one thing
we found is that adding a little
bit of styling in the error
message, like
color or structure,
and maybe omitting
some of the details
can greatly improve
the error message
comprehension by sometimes 30%.
So we're exploring to formalize
these guidelines to make
sure Flutter's error messages
will be more usable and easier
to understand in the future.
MARTIN AGUINIS: What
motivates you personally
to work on Flutter every day?
JA YOUNG SUNG: I think
the fact that Flutter is
open source project is awesome.
I can see that
engineers from Google
and also the community
members outside of Google
work together to create
this app called Flutter.
So it's awesome.
MARTIN AGUINIS: Awesome.
Well, thank you so much.
I had the privilege to
work with you guys on some
of these projects as well,
and it's very exciting,
and really appreciate you
sharing some of your work.